with this guy ben from knees over toes i
bet you he's doing
10 million a year in sales and oh he's
not even he doesn't even have his own
app
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my
let me give you some updates real quick
podcast numbers um
some people can i tease can i teach some
ideas because i think people might be
like uh why do you guys keep telling us
about the podcast and get to the idea so
let me tease the ideas and then you say
your thing
all right i have i have four good ideas
today
one i'll just tell you the names of them
uh
how to beat linkedin super joints
you're gonna like that one or you're
gonna hate it that's another topic
canva for video all right so those are
three that i'm gonna throw at you that
we're gonna talk about after this
you might have some other ones okay now
go back to the podcast update just
really quick i'll make it quick
all right last month we are at uh
last month 60 right last month no last
month we were at 4 30.
this month we were supposed to be at 5
50. i think we might get 600 just so you
know
that's right so i think that's gonna
happen so uh 600
000 listings a month um some more update
stuff tomorrow i'm recording with andrew
wilkinson
um i'm doing another one of his things
his things are always the most popular
so i'm gonna do another one of those um
originally i i signed up to do this
because you just had your baby and i
wanted to record more and you couldn't
do it so we're going to continue doing
that
um tonight i'm flying to new york i had
this guy reach out to me so i'm
um this like a guy named um loeb
uh he started what's his first name i
don't even know his first name uh
michael loeb he started uh priceline and
he invited me
and he like somehow listened to the
podcast or something like that
he's the one with the billions house
yeah so i'm gonna fly to his house
tonight and i'm gonna
interview andrew from new york tomorrow
but um june 3rd sean and i and a bunch
of people
on my team are going to be in austin
we're doing a live event um i think it
was sold out like right away
but yeah we're going to see what we can
do um and then the next we should do
we should do something else uh because
it sold out so quick if there are more
people who want to do it we should uh
i don't know let's capture their info
somehow and let's just do like
i don't know a hangout we'll just i
don't know let's go to a park where
let's go wherever i know we may not have
a venue but
uh let's meet and greet some people who
want to hang out or something i don't
know let's do something let's go to a
bar
who cares and then the next day we're
going to do miami
so we got june 3rd austin june 4th
miami if people want to attend austin's
already sold out
but there is an event right for it miami
we're putting up the event right
yeah and that one can seat 150 people so
that'd be cool if we sell it out but
maybe we won't who knows
so it should have plenty of room last
thing we've got some cool
by the way on the pod we shouted out we
said mayor suarez to the mayor of miami
we said if you're listening to this
we need a venue we need blah blah he
replied on twitter he goes
i got you let's talk and then somebody
else came through it was just like
here's the venue what i don't know if we
want to shout out their name somebody
hooked us up
um with a sweet video no we'll hook them
up we'll shout them out next time
because i've asked them
exactly what they want us to shout out
gotcha so uh i'll i've already asked
some
last things all right we got a couple
guests coming up um
the first one mark lore so marklor
started jet.com which he sold for
billions i think
three billion i think um so that guy's
cool uh and he started something before
that i think it was at diapers.com
yep and he just bought amazon he just
bought the timberwolves uh
nba basketball mba dude i'm such a dork
i don't even know
yeah with with a-rod bought the
timberwolves
and then we have uh mike maples coming
on who
people probably don't know but he's a
pretty big name um bc and he's
uh funded a lot of a ton of star stuff
that you all know
yeah and then finally bill smith this
name
generic name but do you know who bill
smith is
he you love this guy dude you are this
is like your new
your new obsession is bill smith yeah
i'm gonna tell you why so he started
like a
uh like a credit card company in his 20s
and he sold it
right away for millions of dollars then
his second
hit was starting [__] so shipt was based
out of alabama it was basically very
similar to instacart
but uh he self-funded it and then he
sold it for like 600 million dollars
now he's got another thing and the guy's
only like 33.
he's got another thing called hello
landing that i think is really badass so
that guy's coming on soon
but that's the updates we just hired
this guy yesterday um
what's his name brayu dan dan
off to a great start yeah i think it's
um dan i think kerner is his last name
i don't need to try we here at the
hustle have a tremendous culture
we really care about our people dude
after you're hired
we find out your name and after that we
[Laughter]
do you know you want to hear something
funny you know sieva
yes one of my best friends probably like
one of your closest friends i've known
no he's my best friend dude
well i've known him for 10 years almost
i couldn't tell you how to say his last
name
yeah see because this is a key save a
russian name
so i don't think it's important to sam
what's my last name
[Music]
i have no idea what's his first name
well
android but i don't know how to say it
definitely called him
a brew for a while i just don't think
you need to know someone's name i mean i
try really hard to remember people's
name i hate when people
say i'm bad at remembering names so i
always try to remember someone's first
name
but i don't think you need to know
someone's name really to like know them
well i'll just call them bob or chief
[Laughter]
those are the two bub cheeks
uh all right you have something in your
hand what is that that's an idea is that
a stress ball
all right i didn't know you could see
this no it's just chapstick i'm just
trying to put chapstick on
uh are stress balls still a thing i
remember when i was a kid
i went to my mom's office and
her and every other person had a stress
ball on their
uh on their desk and now that i think
about it i haven't seen one of these in
like 10 years
and what a great idea what a genius
name and invention to just be like how
do i sell this like
five cent item to every worker in a
cubicle in america
oh let me call it the stress ball let me
tell you that this gets rid of your
stress and just make it kind of fun to
fiddle with and play with
why aren't more people doing that right
we have fidget spinner for kids
we need the stress spinner for adults i
need i want to invent the next
little silly putty gadget thing that you
feel
addicted to playing with on your desk
good luck i mean
if anyone's gonna be able to do it it's
gonna be you um i had these things on my
desk
uh that i used to fiddle with i think it
annoyed everybody because it kind of
made a little bit of a sound
but um that's who i am at work i breathe
loud
i chew i eat at my desk uh you know i'm
i'm that guy you hate at the office so i
had this thing there's like these
magnetic
there's like a little magnetic um
[Music]
toy or something i don't know what it
was there's a bunch of like tiny little
blocks
that are magnetic so they stick together
and then you just whatever you whatever
shape you put them in it just like
sticks in that shape
or you can pull them apart and stick
them back together like a magnet and
these things are so addictive they
weren't
for playing with at your desk but
they're really effective so
uh maybe maybe it will come out with a
line
by the way i'm i've kick-started a task
to
make us dope merch um
not to make money but uh because i just
want to wear
our own stuff and i figured out the
first two
first two items that we need to have in
our merch well the first one is easy
that one's a notebook so like the joke
that we get in the comments which is
like
you know don't listen while driving
because you want to take notes you'll
crash
yeah we are known to be more dangerous
than drinking while driving so it's
actually
in several states it's outlawed i hope a
notebook is one of the two
a notebook okay notebook is one and
that's actually in motion so i
um for the course i'm making i found
this illustrator giannis who's amazing
i put out this tweet i said who's the
next jack butcher
and then i got a bunch of reply i found
this guy he's amazing
um you know don't tell jack but i think
his stuff might be better than jax you
know
jack's more clever but this guy's actual
illustrations are amazing
i told him i said hey i've been using
this thing called the self journal or
something like that
for a long time um i think the founder
of that listens to the pod
um i forgot do you know her name
catherine yeah
um great product and uh yeah we should
come up with a limited edition notebook
thing so i got that in motion
i'll run it by you but the the merge
stuff that i was thinking about was
when biology came on and we were trying
to beat around the bush and be like so
you're like super rich right
right and then he was like
yeah the most humble way possible was
like i'm post economic
and then i was like oh [__] that is
that is it that is the best phrase so
now i'm getting hoodies made that just
say
post economic and uh you know those will
go out to anybody who wants to buy a
post economic goody so that's the best
one
that's a good one and is that the so
notebook
uh the other one that i was thinking
about you know how we have our harvard
shirts
um because we visited the campus yeah
uh so i think i might sell some bootleg
harvard merch before they shut me down
and all it is is it's harvard yeah i've
been there
uh or like you know love that campus or
yeah
was there an o4 uh like harvard 04 and
on the back it says you know
like tours um so maybe a harvard one but
the the real one that i want to make
there is you know the like
kind of like like take the harvard style
of a sweater sweatshirt or sweater where
it kind of looks like
you know you're a scholar right i went
to this school that's where i learned
that's where i got my education
that but it's just gonna say the
internet it's just gonna say internet um
or say youtube because that's where i
learned everything
and uh there's a lot of other people
that are you're like that too or
everything you learned was just through
the internet that's that's who we should
really be giving credit to
for our education so i'm going to make a
university-looking
piece of apparel that's just either
calling out the internet or youtube or
twitter or something i think the
post-economic thing will make money well
it has to
that's by definition um all right so so
anyways let's
talk about canva for video or do you
want to talk about super joints
no let's do a canvas video so um so
stole this idea from my buddy
suli he tweeted this out he said who's
creating canva
video and i've had the same idea so if
you don't use canva you're probably not
gonna
fully understand this idea not just
because the metaphor but you're gonna be
like
when i describe it you can be like that
sounds simple like because
i'm sure there's stuff like that that
exists no there's not so
canva why don't you give the download
canva i'll talk about why
canva for video needs to exist yeah
canva was started in australia
at this point it's maybe eight years old
uh i i went and did some research there
they have 15 billion
evaluation 500 million dollars in
revenue and what's cool is that this ceo
i think her name is melanie this woman
named melanie she's like
a superstar you hear her talk and you're
like oh i will whatever you say i'm in
her husband are the two co-founders
which is pretty badass because
collectively they own 30
of the company even though it's had a 15
billion dollar evaluation so they
crushed it
but basically the product is uh you can
make really simple images so a lot of
times people use google slides like i do
and you like put an image on there and
then you could write some text on there
and you stick a screenshot and tweet
that
with canva it's all a little bit more
intuitive and you can make really really
simple
uh like uh good-looking designs good
looking design
it's like photoshop for uh
eight-year-old like me
yes photoshop for people who don't know
photoshop that's the best way of
describing it so before when you wanted
to make a marketing brochure
a flyer for your event um you know a
instagram ad a whatever
any kind of image or graphic to go
alongside your product or your event or
whatever it is
you would be like great let me ask my
designer friend to make one or let me go
into
like you know paint or one of these you
know google slides or powerpoint or
whatever and try to make one myself and
it always came out looking budget like
you made it yourself
or you had to overpay somebody who knows
photoshop who has graphic design skills
who knows that this should go at this
angle and that this is a cool way to do
a collage
and like to do a mask and whatever so
what they did was
they just created this enormous library
of templates so you go on there and you
say great i want to make an ad
for a sale well guess what a lot of
people have that problem and so what
they did was they just
created or surfaced hundreds of
templates of
sale you know how to present a sale if
you're a store so now i don't need a
designer i just go in there myself i
change the text
i drop my image into where their image
is and it's like
nicely cut into a circle automatically
or it removes the background
automatically without you having to know
how to do that with the magic wand in
photoshop so um
so that's what canva does it's amazing
it's grown like crazy like you said 500
million in revenue
done very well i think it went public
not long ago so
canva does that for images and they kind
of have some like animation stuff but
nobody has done this for simple videos
so
i'm talking about the whole world has
moved to video rather it's
long form like netflix medium form like
youtube
short form like tick tock even shorter
form like a facebook ad or an instagram
ad
and it still requires people who know
how to edit video in order to make a
simple video
and uh and that's crazy to me and so
there's people who've tried to attack
this from many angles i would say that
what a lot of people try to do is they
try to make figma for video
which is like they take imovie and they
say no it should be in the cloud
you should be able to have multiple
people using it at once you see each
person's mouse moving around the screen
and it saves it all the cloud blah blah
no i think you need canva i think you
need off-the-shelf ready-made
video like short video clips that you
just swap and replace your text and your
images
or your video clips into those and um
there's some things like this that exist
but nobody has cracked this nut
i think canvas most likely to do and i'm
sure they think about this all the time
you know they're
it's not like they're listening to this
and saying oh my god
genius we never thought about video
right but like i do think it's a gnarly
problem
and i think if you are focused on this
you can outflank a lot of people just by
finding the right library of of
templates and then getting the the ux
right where you can make it easy to swap
out
text and images with your own stuff so i
think that this might be a great idea
but
i'll i'm going to default to pessimism
just for the sake of argument
i think that there's a few reasons why
this would be really hard the first
reason is that
well this is actually the the main
reason which is more people use
videos uh use image based stuff and they
do video based stuff
so at a company most everyone would not
most everyone but
a very large percentage of employees
would want to use uh a text-based stuff
whether you're making just a silly
graphic for an internal email whether
you're making a sign that says happy
birthday for your employees
all the way up so you're making the
social post so you're mocking up a
website yadda yadda
um by the way someone made fun of me for
saying yada yada i'm not gonna say it
anymore
uh but anyway uh there's like
so many different instances of that
right is there
actually um that many people that would
huge need dude yes okay
it's the internet text is massive images
is massive
video is massive they're all messed up
how many people
write words on facebook and twitter then
make videos on youtube like but it's a
business it's a business use case
so if you're a business um you need to
be doing all three you need to be
creating text content you need to be
creating image content and you create
video content and you do them at
different times
the video content is often the one that
you need that's the highest value to you
and it works the best in terms of
getting getting people's attention
and so there are tools to do this i
shouldn't say that there's not right
promo.com is uh one of them so promo.com
it has a bunch of templates to let you
do videos i've used it
it is good it is probably the closest
thing
to canvas video there's a startup called
motionbox.io
they're doing this it looks pretty cool
i haven't i haven't actually had a
chance to play with it yet
um cap wing is a big one i've heard of
that one
really popular it's that one's more from
memes so they made it really easy to
make video memes
um we talked about pinata farms also to
when i uh when i was moving out of san
francisco the guy i posted on twitter
that i was selling my gym and the
founder weren't coming
try to come and buy all my gym equipment
that's how i met kaplan the founder of
which one kaplan yeah
nice that's great so i think so here's
my take of what's the opportunity here
the opportunity here for me is
i should be going to try to invest in
all of these companies i think they are
all
like this space is going to be big these
are all viable companies they're all at
different stages
i'm going to go try to put a check into
all of these because i'm such a big
believer in that space
really but the other thing yes for sure
um
the other thing is if you're building
how would you differentiate i think one
of the ways to differentiate the one i
would do
is i would focus on facebook ads i've
talked about this before but
if you think about facebook's one of the
largest companies because it makes a
ton of revenue um what how does it make
its revenue from advertising
who's advertising you know hundreds of
thousands if not millions of
of um of businesses that advertise on
facebook
and if you can do things to help them
advertise either
save them time or make their ads better
you're going to make money
on either one of those two axes and i've
found that
facebook ad tech is sort of of course
there's companies in that space
but there's much less than you would
think there's a lot of people that build
um that try to build on top of platforms
and i think that the facebook ad
platform is a great place to build
products because
if you make someone's life better you
are making them or saving them a lot of
money
and uh so it's not hard to capture you
know your hundred dollars a month
if you're able to do that yeah i think
it's cool i think that there's a
there's a i'm gonna i'm just gonna
default to
bad stuff because that's the dynamic
we're taking right now but uh
the um dude selling stuff for
200 a year that software is so freaking
hard so
go to um are you on your computer right
now are you on your phone
yeah computer all right google buffer
revenue
okay so buffer is this awesome company
i mean it's kind of awesome and they're
one of the first people that made
famous sharing their revenue so if
you're listening out there
type in on google buffer revenue and
you're going to be taken to a
i don't know what the the platform's
called but it's some type of platform
where you could show all their revenue
what's their revenue look like
sean so this post that was 2019 late
was revenue is 21 million they have 75
000 customers um and they make a quarter
million dollars
per employee go to uh go to buffer.com
revenue right so their current one yes
uh actually this is yeah so flat lined
out so that
number i said 2019 that was the peak
2020 was the same 2021 is the same
so still at 21 million if you're
listening go to buffer.com revenue and
they're going to see all their revenue
it's pretty amazing it says
26 of revenue per account yeah and so
what you're gonna see here's what you're
gonna see
the rev on this buffer thing the revenue
goes up really fast
and then it plateaus and that is what
happens
when you sell [__] that costs 20 50 100
it's incredibly hard to keep going it's
really hard to keep going
and that happens and i i study a lot of
these graphs so like there's convertkit
has another one
there's a lot and if you look at the
metrics there's if you google like
average price price price for sas
there's a lot of research on where they
look at companies that go public and
look at how much their software costs
there's this dead zone of like 200
a year or 300 a year or something like
that like and it's like it's incredibly
hard to build a big company when [__]
costs that much
some people have done it mailchimp has
done it um canva has done it
i think it's almost impossible for most
other types of people to do it
well we are talking about canva for
video so i'm gonna hope that it falls
into that category i actually just want
canva to do this because
am i wrong though am i wrong you're not
wrong in that
um there's an effort to acquire
customers it costs money and it takes
time
and if your size of the prize is 26 or
um it is very hard to get to the point
you're talking about which is
going public or being a multi-billion
dollar no but my point though is not
necessarily if you're listening to this
and you want to build something that has
to be the goal
my but when i think about stuff
sometimes i think
now this isn't always but sometimes it's
far easier
to be a small fish in a massive market
than it is to like be a big fit like you
know like i
i'd rather be like the shitty person in
uh something that's just booming
because like it'll be way easier to
crush it yeah although you also say
um you know niches get riches type of
thing right where
you'd rather be a big fish in a small
pond well i i said i don't always think
that way i'm saying like
if i want to build something that can
just make a good like living then yeah
that's one thing if i want to create
something that could take off i would
probably want to do the other way
right and i think you know the thing you
just said that's important is you said a
market that's booming that's different
than a big market
so a big market is a already big market
a market that's booming is a growing
market
and so if i was gonna rank the three i
would say
small fish in a booming market then big
fish in a small market and lastly
small fish in a already big market yeah
i think i
agree with you can we talk about super
joints
yeah i looked it up while you were
talking and i have a lot to say about
this
okay well i don't even know what you
looked up this was my own name of an
idea i had so
much super joints is do you remember so
we talked about the book happy body
okay okay yeah yeah yeah let's go here
first super joints
is also the name of a book at google
super joints it looks just like the
happy body
yeah it looks exactly like it like 1970s
or 80s like
design um but we don't have to talk
about that i thought well the thing i
was thinking about is
so my mom uh is staying with me right
now
she's been here for last few days and uh
you know
my mom has like always got some ache and
pain
and uh and she does a good job of like
like trying to exercise and stretch and
you know like whatever do the things
that she can do to you know
we bought a special pillow for the bed
so that like kind of if she's in bed
watching tv
like she's not in a crappy posture or
whatever we try things but this is a
every
aging person problem is that you know
you get bad back bad knees bad hip bad
shoulder whatever right like you've
risked pain
this stuff comes up and i started
thinking like okay
you know i think that you this is going
to be a this is a massive massive market
that nobody really is able to do much
with um
[Music]
and so i thought what is the what is the
solution i think there's two solutions i
think the end solution is
fixing it from the inside so that's some
version of like
stem cells or like regenerative
therapies where you're able to
um to regrow cartilage or strengthen
strengthen the tendons or do something
like that to reduce the the irritation
inflammation
um okay i don't know too much about that
i don't know where we're at in the stem
cell world
then there's the fix it from the outside
and i thought oh this might be actually
easy
so i was watching somebody move a couch
you know my neighbor had a truck
and they're moving and like you know it
was one person just with a dolly just
moving this like huge couch and bookcase
and all this stuff
and um it got me thinking like man with
these simple
tools that we've made that man has made
you have so much leverage you can
lift heavy objects why don't we just
have these like
as like a little knee brace that people
wear
that just helps you when you're trying
to get up it's just like a little spring
action
that is like a super joint it is and
it's it is a
a sort of an external fix to the problem
of
joint pain that sounds like such an
infomercial thing
i can i can imagine this now in my head
exactly that's exactly what i thought of
my head i see the old lady sitting on
the couch she's trying to get up and
she's struggling and then it like fades
yeah it fades to black and white and
she's in pain and then it's like her
again on the couch and she gets up and
she just
gets up effortlessly because she's got
this little thing she wears around her
knee
that essentially like as she does this
motion it's a spotter
and i just thought why don't we have
spotters for our own carrying our own
body weight
so um how do you think of this i think
that that you're
cool it sounds like some shitty alibaba
product that you
i think you're thinking about totally
wrong so like what you're talking about
is like
a silly brace i want to like actually
solve the problem and there's
three companies that i've been paying
attention to that are in this space
um and they're all centered around
mobility so what i've noticed amongst my
friends
and like the people in austin now is a
lot of them are less focused on lifting
heavy weights
and more focused on um this manly
version of yoga that
we call mobility right right it's
it's yoga i mean i'm doing mobility
training yeah
it's stretching yes
it's a little bit more interesting than
yoga and i do it a lot as well so
there's three things that i like there's
one called the ready state the
readystate.com
there's another one called i actually
don't know how you pronounce it but it
looks like it's uh it's go
wad uh so the word go and then i think
it stands for workout of the day
uh i'm a paying subscriber of it it's
great
and then the third one is the knees over
toes knees over toes guy have you seen
knees over toes guy
dude i'm all into this yeah i've done
the whole program it's wonderful oh you
did
i've done the whole thing it's so good
so did your vertical leap go up
yeah but i yeah it all works wonderful i
i love it but
basically the first two that i've
described so gowad and the ready state
it's an app that you pay a hundred
dollars and the founders of goad i've
actually talked about on this podcast
two years ago i think and or a year and
a half ago and they messaged me and they
said
you're the numbers that you're it was
someone who works there so the numbers
that you're saying are way smaller than
we actually are
and i think i said they're doing half a
million a month in sales um
right and so they're both apps where you
spend
30 minutes a day and they just do
stretches it's just
the simplest app ever it's just a video
that shows you a stretch
and it counts down from 60 seconds the
other thing is this guy named knees over
toes guy
uh that's like his handle his knees over
toes guy his name is ben patrick
and he got he went viral on on on in
on tick-tock and instagram i found him
on instagram and
it's basically this crew of guys and
he's like the leader
but he's they're like these quote manly
men like they like they they like are
strong looking
and fit and all that but they um
like stretch a ton and they're really
focused on one-legged
pistol squats and being able to touch
your toes
and we should say he's called knees over
toes guy because
in classical kind of like training
anytime you train they're always like
don't let your knees go over your toes
because they thought that's how you get
injured that's when you're doing a squat
wrong or a lunge
oh no you're not lunging right you want
your knee to never go past your toe if
you're biking they always say the same
adjust your seat height so your knees
doesn't go over your toes and this guy
was like hey
i blew out my knee i tore my acls
and um and you know i started trying to
figure out how do i actually strengthen
my legs how do i strengthen my knees so
that i don't get injured again and in
fact
he ended up getting stronger through his
like so he did some self-experimentation
and whatever
and then now he's i don't know 43 45
years
old he's got like a i forgot how old he
is he's in his 40s or even maybe even
his
like maybe he's 50. that's all
he's got a 43 inch vertical leap he can
dunk he's like he jumps higher now than
he did in his 20s
and he's been athletic the whole time
it's just that now he strengthens his
leg in this this
way that breaks all the rules so his
stuff is intentionally
let your knee go over your toes why
because we want to stabilize our knees
when they're in these
uncomfortable compromised positions
we'll do it in a controlled way now
so that you don't get hurt later so
that's the theory behind this stuff
and this guy has almost 500 000
followers on twitter
or on instagram and he is putting on an
absolute master class
in marketing i followed him and like i
i because i'm a internet guy i know
exactly what he's doing and i'm like
it's working it's working
i bought it he charges 50 a month and
the reason he charges 50
a month is because the churn is probably
astronomical so the average user i bet
only stays for three months because when
you do the program like i did
i just wrote it down i'm like oh i know
exactly what to do it's just like right
it's as basic as a pdf
um so like i know what to do but he got
my 150 bucks over three months
i got results i loved it and the way
that this guy's getting um he's
basically doing you know the best person
i've ever seen at this
fitness uh marketing is that woman kayla
it's new i think her name is
and she has it's scenes and she has an
app called sweat that's scaled to 100
million dollars in sales
if you're a guy you probably don't know
who she is it's my wife sarah used it
and she crushed it and all she did was
sell pdf and then eventually it
it went to an app with this guy ben from
knees over toes i bet you he's doing
10 million a year in sales and he's not
even he doesn't even have his own app
there's all these apps called trainerize
uh in similar apps where what you do is
you just put your program on their thing
and you give them a little tiny cut of
the revenue
it's a pretty amazing business i mean
the high churn but like it looks like a
really fun lifestyle business run
totally it's uh what we were talking
about with judge judy and michael buffer
last episode i think it was we talked
about building a personal monopoly
and finding your niche uh that's what
this guy did
brilliant branding knees over toes guy
right
beautiful beautiful branding to to latch
onto that
it's a different it's it's sort of um i
don't know if you remember but i
one of my kind of core content beliefs
came from the guy who writes wait but
why and
our actually his buddy there's two guys
behind it so this is not tim urban it's
the guy who who helps him with his
business andrew
right he was nice enough took a call
from me one day
and uh i said yeah i'm thinking about my
content and
what's the strategy what's the brand and
he goes i have a really simple way of
thinking about it
he goes you know in the matrix we have
uh morpheus reaches out and says do you
want the red pill or the blue pill
meaning like
you want to keep living in your fantasy
land if the way that you were told
things are
or do you want the truth that's the red
pill the harsh red pill that you got to
swallow
and neo chooses the red pill because he
wants to know the truth and he basically
said that's what
the best way to build your content brand
is by giving people red pills
um so people you know if people think
one way or society tells you x
i'm going to tell you the truth and
here's why um and so
that's what these over those guys did
it's a perfect red pill
uh everybody says don't move your knee
over your toe i'm the knees over toes
guy
and so he built his niche there he built
his brand there he went viral on tick
tock by showing
some pretty amazing stuff and then he's
translating that into a business
now i have a quick opportunity for
somebody who wants to do this
so one of the things that he does in his
program you tell me you did the program
uh my trainer takes pieces of the
program and gives it to me but
did you buy that gadget that you that
you wear on your foot the monkey foot
thing
yeah and who did you buy that from
the monkey foot guys uh it's i think
it's called animal house fitness is that
who you bought it from yeah
and is that his brand or is that
somebody else's brand it does not appear
to be his but i didn't realize not his
correct okay so
knees over toes guy if you're listening
this is for you uh or
if you're not gonna do it we can pair
you with a hustler who's gonna do this
you need to be selling this device okay
so wait yeah
so the what this thing is is the boot
it's like imagine a ski boot
that you put on your foot you step into
it and under the boot
there you can put a tiny little dumbbell
so you can put like a five pound 10
pound whatever 15 pound dumbbell into it
and so then when you do leg extensions
or calf
sorry like knee raises things like that
you have like
weighted resistance and it helps you
build strength faster and so it's one of
his like core things did i miss anything
on it yeah he also makes slant boards
so yeah i i think that like there's an
entire brand to be made around this like
i i wouldn't call it masculine because i
think women like this too but a
non-yoga-esque
uh like i would i don't want to go as
far to say it's feminine but you guys
get the idea
like a a well it's gotten cooler because
tom brady
you know the greatest quarterback of all
time came out with the tb12 program
the town brady 12 program and people
like great tom brady you're still
playing you just won the super bowl last
year i don't know what he is 42 43 years
old
this is the oldest you know quarterback
to win a super bowl how are you still
playing
um and you know he he credits basically
like he eats super
clean and then he doesn't do like
strength and explosive training he does
all flexibility mobility pliability
that's what he is those are his focuses
he's like that's how i don't get hurt
brother and we talked about this a year
and a half ago i was
all about this you were talking about
the subreddit you visit right which is a
mobility subreddit right yes i've been
all about this the reason i'm all about
this is you can feel it in your body
um like i like i i do different
athletic challenges and i've done
challenges where i try to get incredibly
strong
and i know how i feel i'm like oh i feel
kind of swollen i feel bloated
i don't feel awesome and then i do these
things where i just
try to squat all the way with my butt in
the ground with no weight and i'll just
sit there for
you know 10 minutes or i'll just work on
flexibility and i'm like oh i feel so i
feel alive i feel so much better
and so i've been talking about this
forever i just sent you an instagram a
guy named the flexible
that's another amazing name i love the
flexi bowl you act
you immediately know what it is it's a
strong person that's flexible
um and so anyway i'm all about this
niche of i don't know what we're gonna
call this
like uh uh flexibility culture
whatever it is i think that these things
are the best i think there's a bunch of
interesting things going on in this
space i've seen a few people
i've seen this one guy watch this thing
called the human garage and they go
there
you go there and they stretch you so i
love all these things i'm totally into
them
i also have seen that the tests the
mobility
tests go semi-viral so i saw something
or
i don't even know it was me or my mom i
don't know one of us saw it then they
shared it with the other and then
everybody in the family did the test and
all it was is this get up test so you
sit on the ground
indian style cross-legged oh sorry is
indian style not pc
i think it's about the native american
indians so you know you might piss off
two groups
but uh yeah you said on the ground
indian style as we used to say back in
second grade
and uh and then you're supposed to get
up and the idea is
that you i think you like for every part
of your body that you have to use to
touch the ground to get up
you sort of deduct a point so like for
me when i have when i'm sitting like
that first of all i can barely even sit
like that second of all
if i have to get up it's like a [__]
process dude it's like
roll to the left now i'm laying down
elbow on the ground
forearm on the ground hand on the ground
second hand pushes me now i'm in a
push-up position
now i get to my knees now i stand
upright i stand up like an 80 year old
and the test says you're basically have
the fitness of an 80 year old you have
the mobility of an 80 year old
because i lose it's like you start at
seven points and you deduct a point for
everything that touches the ground
something like that and so then i did it
and then my mom did it my dad did it my
sister it's like everybody does it
and so there's something interesting
there of let's say you wanted to build
a program like this or sell a tool like
this there's something interesting like
we talked about last time of
personality tests uh iq tests horoscope
tests people's most interesting subject
is
themselves similarly here i think you
could build
a following or an audience by by giving
people a simple
diagnostic a simple test can you like
it's like the kind of can you pat your
head and rub your belly at the same time
it's like everybody wants to try it when
they hear oh that's hard that sounds
easy right
um i saw one the other day that was like
take your arms to the side
reach them straight above your head and
then like do they
um like keep your arms straight so do it
yeah keep your arms straight
yeah so you okay you're you're not so
bad but like you're tight you can see
your tongue tie at my left his is like
if your
bicep is able to like touch your ear
while maintaining the straightness and
like crossing
you're able to cross your hands then
your shoulders are
like adequately you know flex flexible
and mobile
and if not then you want to do these
three exercises to improve that
and so i love this model of sort of
diagnose the problem and then prescribe
your solution
and uh i think that would be a cool way
to kind of grow this but i'm with you
that hey
flexibility mobility pliability i think
these are where the fitness trends are
going
uh right now and to wrap it up i'll say
it's never been easier to make money off
this type of thing this guy
uh ben nisovatos guy as i said he
doesn't have his own app
he's using trainerize this other app you
can literally launch this
today today uh with 20 bucks
um all right you want to talk about uh
linkedin stuff or
uh what do you google whatever let's do
linkedin stuff so you said something the
other day
you go this guy lives like
down my block and he created i don't
even know what was it some guy who's
done something cool he's built some cool
business student loan hero
right and you were like he lives i don't
know how long he lives like that
like ten doors down ten doors down all
right so great so
i don't know how you found that out but
i'll tell you it's pretty funny i
tweeted a picture of myself in front of
my new house and he dm'd me and goes i
don't want to be weird but i
i know that house i lived on the block
so that and that's a cool moment you met
somebody who's like kind of
professionally relevant to you
that's also locally relevant to you yeah
what does that mean
i think that there's an opportunity to
build a location-based
professional network or professional
networking tool especially now that the
world has gone remote
so you got a bunch of people relocating
you have people getting out of
offices where they would normally be
seeing kind of like peers and co-workers
and stuff like that all the time
and most people think the answer is
create a co-working space or some kind
of like flexible work
space where you go and you work and
that's where you're going to get
professional interaction
well i've actually seen kind of this
other trend which is
you discovering people who live around
you that are like
like kind of like interesting business
people that you would want to meet with
and you guys kind of both opted in to be
who are you learning this from
well i'm saying i had a similar
experience the other day did a call
guys like where do you live i said oh i
live in this this little place right
outside uh san francisco
he goes oh my friend just moved there or
my friend lives there too
he's the you know chief prada officer at
blankety blank company
which kind of i was like oh sick uh well
i don't want to get out of his identity
or whatever but like
a company don't worry about it it's kind
of like a well-known company he's like
oh yeah he lives out there too i was
like great uh i'll intro you guys you
guys should hang out
because like it's like oh like you know
we're sort of
like we could be friends and we live
near each other so that's the excuse of
why we might
actually hang out so i thought that's
kind of interesting what if you could
get people to basically just say
here's my job and here's where i live or
here's where i where i am
and it just notifies you about other
people that are
also there that are kind of like
professionally relevant to you if you
could kind of figure out people's
like i don't know without being a douche
but like
if there's a ceo you kind of want to
talk to other like c c levels
serious guy yeah not like the product
manager or some other company that's not
like super relevant
to you um so i think that would be kind
of cool as a way to
as a cool product to bootstrap a new
style of professional network and a new
style of interaction
and first of all let's even mention that
linkedin freaking everyone says the same
thing linkedin
sucks how does everyone use linkedin and
yet we all use it or
a lot of people do i don't use it
anymore but you get the idea
yeah it's it is used and it is still the
number one even though we all
say how much it sucks um and i think
it's true
what i think that what that what i think
that it means is
you have to find an angle that's not a
direct angle you can't beat linkedin by
just building linkedin again
and being like but i have better
features i have better design
that's not going to work so the best
angle so every time all right i see so
many companies that are trying to
beat linkedin and i think it's a worthy
thing to try to do i think because i
think it can be done
and i think that you can build a big
business and if you can't un bundle them
or whatever
crush them you could do pretty good and
the only times i've seen people do it
that seems any traction
is they divide it up into subgroups so
it's typically race
and it's typically gender um i think or
it could be industry like angellist did
it with startups angelus basically took
the whole startup
company's jobs and candidates off of
range off of linkedin and just said that
we can do this better
i've never seen it done really with
industries i don't agree with your
i don't totally agree with that
assessment because kind you're kind of
right
yeah i guess you are right but i do i
haven't seen
many i've seen a ton of women tips uh
women focused ones so there's girl boss
there's this other one called
levo i think it was called l-e-v-o uh
like also girl boss failed
right so yeah to be fair yeah yeah yeah
but there's chief chief.com
which i have no idea if it's succeeding
or not but it certainly seems like it is
there's um and there's a lot of black
focused ones i don't remember all their
names but i remember seeing them float
around and
they seemed mildly successful like they
have some traction but obviously i'm not
a user
um but i've seen race and gender
linkedin
so here's the ones that i think have
worked i think angellist worked
right through three to four billion
dollar company and
if i'm a startup uh i might have a
linkedin but i'm i i
well with all of my startups i've found
better luck finding
jobs and candidates through angelus um
dribble did this yeah so dribble was
like uh if you're a designer linkedin's
kind of like it's hard to
show that you're a good designer there i
would say uh behance did it better than
triple because they had 175 million
exit yeah so so designed let's just say
where you're putting your portfolio up
there you're networking with other
designers and then other people can come
find they find images and then they say
who's who made this
and then they basically hire you right
so i think that was kind of that was
kind of successful git
github github for developers exactly
that's another one and then there's the
low end where it's like
upwork right where it's just like they
went you know kind of like geography
like you were saying
and upwork basically says here's a way
to find you know workers can find jobs
and jobs can find workers
um but we're gonna go for like kind of
like outsourced
labor arbitrage type of thing so i think
those have all worked
now here's a different like take
here's what here's a company i invested
in that i think has a cool chance of
beating linkedin i want to describe
their strategy but i don't want to use
the silicon valley jargon you know this
word orthogonal
no have you heard people say this that
it's like yeah you have to take an
orthogonal angle or it's an orthogonal
or well orwellian
no it just means like you don't go
directly like you don't
beat linkedin like okay here's the
example
let's say you think um powerpoint sucks
you're like i'm gonna build a better
powerpoint the way to build a better
powerpoint is not to make
slides that are easier to make it's to
look at the fact that people use slides
to give their bosses presentations about
how like
how the business is doing and actually
the orthogonal way to attack that is to
build dashboards that automate them that
are always automatically updated that
your boss can just check
and now you don't even need slides right
right like in order to build a
vulnerability
to build the best hotel business you
don't create better hotels necessarily
you get other people to list their homes
you get airbnb exactly so so orthogonal
just means sort of attacking it from
another
angle so here's here's an orthogonal uh
attack on linkedin
there's this company called palette.xyz
have you seen this
palette how do i spell it palette
p p a l l e t uh dot x y z i think
that's the name
you're not gonna learn too much from
this but i'll tell you kind of like
where you could see how did you find
these guys dude how do you find all this
[__] man
bro you i've already given people the
the the secret sauce which is
be super curious and then surround
yourself with interesting people and
then
share it right like my my crew i think
ben found palette or
maybe zach found palette i'm not sure
somebody's fun palette i talked to the
guy behind it
he's awesome he's like a 23 year old
ex stanford guy like you just talked to
him you're like oh okay you're going to
win
like it's whether it's this business or
the next one or the next one or the next
one like
you're gonna win you're clearly super
smart you're way ahead of your time in
terms of just like polish as a ceo
and you're an engineer and you recruited
under other good engineers great
um but what he's building is actually
pretty cool we found him because
um i am pretty interested in like what
i'm calling like kind of like the
creator stack or basically like
the solopreneur's playbook so i look at
people like pomp
right pomp is uh a creator
he creates content in the niche of
crypto you can say who pomp is i
actually don't think everyone knows
okay pop his name's anthony pompliano
he's uh kind of
like a friend of ours we don't know him
super well but he's friendly he's come
on the pod we've been on his pod
and he's super well known he used to
work at facebook then he was like
i don't know chief something at snapchat
left really early
or like kind of like that didn't last
very long went on his own and started
creating content about bitcoin in like
2016 2017-ish
and as bitcoin got more popular he got
more popular so he's got like i don't
know
a million followers now he's got a sub
stack with 170
000 you know like subscribers or paid
subscribers he's a bitcoin media
personality but like
he's on cnbc to talk big anytime bitcoin
happens pump tell us
is it good or is it bad yeah he's kind
of a troll on purpose like
i like pomp but he like he like uh [__]
the people i don't call him a troll i
think he's um
somebody said this and they said it in a
way that was derogatory but i actually
think it's like
a good description of like people like
this they called him a carnival barker
which is basically like a hype man like
somebody who's going to just keep
keep pounding the pavement and keep keep
knocking on doors and saying
saying the message i don't mean
disrespectfully i mean like he's funny
like he's like he's a [__] yeah and
he has a good time he's got a good
personality
and he's extremely talented with content
creation and branding so
we'll talk about one of his other
projects that just came out but anyways
my point is
uh pomp created this uh job board called
crypto jobs or something like that like
uh he's like you want a job in crypto
and he you're i'm a trusted guy in
crypto
if you want to work in crypto here's my
personal job board
i thought oh that's kind of interesting
like we've talked in the past about job
boards andrew wilkinson talked about how
good of a business
job boards are and um i thought
i wonder how successful individuals
creators job boards could be
and the reason i'm interested in this is
because hey that's like kind of like my
career path is
being a creator and i think about like
the previous wave
like tim ferriss and those guys they
didn't have any of these different
business models they didn't have rolling
funds
they didn't have ghost kitchens they
didn't have job boards as like
a way to capitalize on their audience
they just sold books
and then like that was kind of it and
now creators have a whole different
arsenal of ways to make money one of
which is a job board
so he did this with with pomp he did uh
pallet does this with
uh you know lenny the kind of like the
product management guy
so lenny's got a job board if you want
to become a pm
well you could just go to like linkedin
or indeed
but if you're a pm and you follow lenny
and you love his content about being a
better pm
it kind of makes sense palette is the
job board software that all these
creators use
bro do you think that's going to be a
huge thing i've created job boards use a
wordpress plugin
yeah so here's the here's the difference
uh this is like a classic
um i think this is a classic mistake
which is like
webflow dude i could use wix right like
shopify
i can do this on squarespace it's like
the there is a benefit to
when something really focuses on a use
case and a niche
and attacks it from in a different way
so what they did was um they built this
job board thing to go to creators or
communities so like for
the hustle you guys could be the hustle
could be do you guys have a job order
now
we we yeah we launched one as a test
how did it do uh it didn't do well but i
wouldn't say it's because the idea is
bad it's just that we were
when we were deciding between trends and
something else
that something else was a job board and
we were like let's do this other thing
so these individual creators guess how
much they're making off their job board
i would love to know i don't know give
me a guess what do you think lenny's
making off his job board
100 grand a year at most so
i don't want to blow up these guys his
own economics but let's just say i
looked at
10 of these and i looked at okay how
much money do each of these make
people of their level of fame which is
like they're not
truly famous they're like niche famous
yeah internet famous
quarter million dollars and pop pomp i
think is going to make about a million
dollars off his job board this year
he's going to be running off his job and
and he doesn't have to create content
every day
he doesn't have to you know get on right
so his newsletter he's got to write a
[__] newsletter every morning right
like that that's his
people pay him 9.99 and he's got to
write the newsletter every morning that
job board
that's just for free after already
building the audience so
what's the um what's the business model
for pallet uh
so they basically take a percentage of
whatever the creator's making so and so
how does the creator make money
creator makes money because the
companies who want to access
talent in that niche go and they pay the
or a thousand dollars to um to post
their job
and so they pay let's say a thousand
dollars per per job posting
they're gonna get candidates that are
highly qualified uh the creator can sort
of like
do two things they can take some of the
jobs and they can sort of like
boost them and basically say if i was if
i was you guys these are companies that
i would go work for so you can endorse
the jobs you can also endorse the
candidates so you can take your audience
and just instead of just saying hey
my full audience is this you can say hey
these
400 people are like kind of like the the
the top the cream of the crop in terms
of my audience these guys are like kind
of like the superstar talent
and so you actually have to pay more to
access them um
or when they match with this i'll when
you post a job i will actually specially
message those people
um and that's like kind of like a
premium offering so so they basically
give you the software to do this the
reason i think this is interesting for
linkedin linkedin is one
giant central uh like job board
basically right so like
that's the way linkedin makes money is i
forgot we were even talking about
linkedin
um so so i think this is a distributed
version of linkedin it's basically
saying
nobody nobody's going to build a 500
million person social network
for professionals professionals again
that's linkedin's advantage but what if
instead of 500 million people on one
network
you had 500 you know you know 50 000
people
on whatever 100 networks or whatever it
is do the math and so you
you you split it where um like one
example they have is
um there's a like a community of
developers who all write let's say
angular angular is a javascript like
framework
so they have a big discord of thousands
of angular developers well they should
have a job board
for people who are trying to hire
developers who write angular right who
angular developers um that would be the
business model for running that
community
for putting in all the hard work and
running a great angular community
the job board would be a great way and
if i'm an employer i'd rather go to the
angular community and write on their job
board
than just post on linkedin wow so this
is this company they've like raised
legit money
who palette yeah they're not like a it's
like i mean they raised four million
dollars
yeah it's like a startup startup um
that's pretty wild um
so you kind of turned my opinion on this
who all anyone interesting invested in
this besides you
yeah a lot of the creators because a lot
of the creators like holy [__] this is
great
like i will invest in this and i'll be a
user of it
because this solves a problem of mine
right if i've done all the hard work to
build a free audience and build trust
with them and build a kind of a niche
i'm i'm an authority in a niche and that
niche is like a job
maybe it's design maybe it's product
management maybe it's
you know developers or back-end
engineers machine learning experts
whatever
it once i've done that if you have a way
for me to monetize that doesn't require
me to get up there and either
teach or write content every day i'm in
right
and the economics seemed to work and and
then the more
job boards the more niche job boards
that get created through this network
now they can just when a company wants
to post a job you can say hey
you only you know you came here to post
on the angular community
but we have these five other job boards
that are all for developers would you
like to cross post
and they can help like give get more
reach on the job and they can help those
creators get more money without
marketing themselves so these guys yeah
you changed my opinion it's pretty dope
and the reason why it's interesting is
the way that you described it was far
better than what i thought it was going
to be is
zip recruiter do you know zip recruiter
i know that ads i don't
what do they do that's different they
it's oh that's the same thing it's one
place and they go post on indeed and
they post on all the job boards right
yeah so zip recruiter um
at the time and still could be the case
they were the fastest growing company
out of
la and the largest series a company
ever meaning their valuation was the
highest ever for a series a
um and i believe it was it's crazy how
times have changed but like their series
a
they value them at like hundreds of
millions of dollars now it's like way
different
um but um and what they do is you uh
so they raise uh i'm looking at no i
think they're are they not like public
like
they advertise on bill simmons podcast
like yeah they're probably close to
so their series a they raised at a 300
million valuation
which unfortunately is considered small
now probably but
they um they're they're going to go
public yeah they're public size
and they they make hundreds of millions
of dollars in revenue and what you do is
they make a really so they what was that
term orwellian what's that
orthogonal or orthogonal uh that's
it's a good term i'm going to steal that
one um so what they've done is
they do a couple things and if you told
me what they were trying to do i would
actually say oh wow this is way too
complicated i don't think this would
work
but basically they do a couple things
the first thing is that they make it
really easy
to um post your job anywhere so you just
click you upload the job description and
it posts in every single place
you don't have to go to each one and so
that's why an employer posts there
the second thing that they do is now
once once they got all these people to
start posting
uh their jobs on ziprecruiter you can
now go to ziprecruiter.com and it says
look for a job
and so they get um they get um
recruits right there and then on the
back end they've now created a way that
you can manage your hiring process
and the way that they make money i
believe is by uh
um i think it's um software so you you
can you can
you can pay a fee to get access to uh uh
like the crm
as well as the post for free or you
could do one off although
po you got to pay for it to be posted in
all the places and
it's a the this strategy works really
well
so i'm on board i think ziprecruiter is
is great uh
but it's one of those like i don't know
if this idea is going to work i thought
it was worth a bet so i invested right
so i'm talking my book a little bit here
but
it's more like all startups are you know
it's
unlikely that they succeed i wouldn't
say the probability is that they go
defeat linkedin it's just that i thought
oh wow that is smart actually you're not
going to build the 500 million person
social network that's just so hard you
have to
who's going to be able to do that
instead if you just say
well all these individual creators and
communities are already building their
own little network what if i created a
decentralized job board
the job board instead of being in one
spot it actually lives
in each one of their little communities
and that makes sense to me because like
our friend andrew
um uh you know andrew chen you know my
favorite uh person who blocks me on
twitter
you're you're a good buddy he's got a
great growth blog
and then you know a lot of a lot of
growth marketers yeah
growth if he had his own if he had his
own growth job board he would you know
with essentially zero work
probably making i don't know easily 150
grand a year 250 grand a year
um of companies that want to hire growth
growth hackers and growth marketers like
andrew and so
that would be a better more targeted
place to hire somebody from
than going to this sort of general sea
of job app you know
job applications and um so i think that
that that part is what made sense to me
with this
although i was like you when when i
first heard this i didn't want to take
the meeting i was like
great like you know uh
bloggers are gonna become like blogger
job boards what the hell is that right
like
i remember reading once that i can't get
this out of my head which is like
they go sub stack where b players teach
c
players what a players do it looks like
oh [__]
that's so good that's such a kill shot
who said that
i think it was hunter walk i think it
was on twitter
um and you know but it's such a good
call out right like the
it's in many ways it's true right the
most successful people the
the true icons you know they're not
creating a ton of content typically
and um sometimes they do when they
retire sometimes it's part of the growth
strategy but for the most part elon musk
doesn't have a sub stack right
he's not trying to teach you and sell
you a course on how to be a good ceo
because he just is a good ceo and makes
all his money there
so often it's it is a b
player teaching a c player what the a
players do
and i think that's like a harsh but true
critique
um and you know i myself you know feel
like that many times
um and i think that's when i was like
from that angle i was like oh will this
job board thing work
but once i looked into it i was like
this actually makes a lot of sense
can we speak this is kind of relevant
can we wrap up with this thing you have
here about
you're never uh even when you're late
you're early
yeah this is a very typical you thing
so let's end all the philosophy i asked
i asked sean
last week to we said let's come up with
a 10-minute
short episode this morning i get a
message from him
saying i just did it this morning and i
that's all i said and i clicked play and
it said
the first line was like i just woke up
this morning and lost five hundred
thousand dollars i was like up hooked
i'm in
and that where we can't run this on
sunday we have to run this right now
and so what what happened and um i guess
what's this
you're not late type of thing you want
me to talk about the the thing from this
morning you're going to talk about this
you're not late thing
this late thing okay the late thing so
i was um i was looking back
and uh i was doing a little kind of
retrospect i said
so i graduated from college you did one
today when you like lost all this
no no this is like a month ago i was
looking back at 2010
and i remember being in college and i
you know i had an iphone
so i knew apple was the [__] i used
google constantly i used chrome and
i knew i knew google was the [__] um i
was a believer
in tesla i think i owned tesla shares at
like i don't know
20 20x cheaper than they are today um
so i saw all these companies and at the
time google seemed super established
right google's been around for
for google had been around in 2010 for
so many years right like
over a decade plus or whatever same with
apple was even older right 20 years old
um they seemed like mature companies
they didn't seem like where all the
upside was
and i looked back and i just did a
little analysis i said when i graduated
from college how big was google what was
the market cap
if i just invested that day um and this
isn't like when you say oh if you
invested in bitcoin in 2010
you'd be worth a gajillion dollars well
yeah um
that's because bitcoin was worth like 10
cents back then you know and it was like
nobody knew if bitcoin was gonna be a
thing
but with google it was clear it was
gonna be a thing apple it was clear it
was gonna be a thing facebook it was
clear it was gonna be a thing
like my whole college was obsessed with
it was pretty obviously gonna be
you know somewhat successful and so
here's some numbers
2010 when i graduated google's revenue
was 5 billion
today its revenue is 55 billion dollars
and you could do the same thing with
amazon for facebook
and if you had just bought those
companies back then
you would have made 10 extra money right
so like if i had just taken my last year
of college tuition
um and i just said hey dad instead of
putting that into into college let's
just put into these four companies that
like
we use their products daily they are
already successful they're not going to
google's not going to tank it's not
going to fail
let's just invest in google you know we
would have 10 extra money or whatever by
now i don't know the exact numbers it's
not what's important
the lesson is even when it feels
late like you're established if it is a
mega trend
mega trends have way more room to run
than you expect
some of the mega trends were the
internet as a whole the internet was a
mega trend
mobile was a mega trend and apple's been
running on that mega trend for a while
um
you know cloud cloud is a mega trend and
you see aws
aws is big and every year it just grows
at the rate of the fastest growing
startup
but aws is already like you know 40 50
billion dollars in revenue and it'll
just keep growing really fast
um and so so i think that uh mega trends
are not to be underestimated and
i was listening to this peter teal thing
peter thiel
who is like you know investor uh was one
of the first investors on facebook
created paypal that sort of thing
peter thiel said you know there are many
money managers out there you know
financial advisors investment bankers
uh mutual funds and they'll all try to
pitch you their strategy hedge funds
they'll all tell you how they're going
to beat the market how they're going to
do well he goes
as an investor often it is the simplest
and stupidest strategy the most obvious
strategy that is all you need to do he
goes
uh in 20 i think it was 2013 or 2012
uh jim cramer the mad money guy on cnbc
who by the way i think is like pretty
awesome i think
i think he's like a pretty good guy and
his picks are
not so bad are they uh i think
i don't know i don't i don't look too
much into him i don't know if he's a
good guy i've never met him
but um i know that for his he's an
entertainer right he's on tv not because
he's the best stock picker he's on tv
because
he's plays really well in the living
rooms of america
right and uh so anyways he did something
which is what entertainers do he made up
a catchy phrase
he called facebook amazon uh netflix and
google
fang he made that up yeah he invented
fang in 2013.
and peter till pointed out he goes if
you had just put your money into fang
which were obviously great companies
there were technology companies that
were growing
um and you didn't even need to know how
fast they were going but if you just
said
these are solid companies that you know
seems like everybody in america is using
their products
um you would have made six times your
money in the last uh eight years
and he goes that would beat the
performance of almost ever any money
manager or headphone headphone
hedge fund or investment banker that
you're that you're thinking of working
with
he goes the problem is those strategies
are too stupid
even if even if a financial advisor
thought that that was a good bet
they could never charge you the you know
one percent of all your assets that they
charge as their fees
to just tell you to invest in facebook
amazon netflix and google and
go go to sleep like don't don't touch it
for 10 years
but in reality that was the best advice
and he goes
um the same thing he goes i believe the
same thing is true for bitcoin today
and uh it's the the advice is almost so
so simple that a money manager would be
embarrassed to say that this is their
strategy
so they'll come up with a more
complicated strategy that will actually
underperform
well i don't just buy bitcoin and
chilling i agree with that sentiment
i don't think it's just a money manager
thing and i would say look at your
actions and
my actions are similar to yours but we
are we do a lot of silly stuff
um you're investing in risky startups
when you're right now you're
pontificating
um that you think bitcoin is gonna 6x in
eight years
if you think that it's gonna six x in
eight years put all your money in it
then
right um so i don't think to be fair i
pretty much have at this point
and i and i'm using you as an example i
i'm incredibly guilty of this well and
just i i mean you as a human being um
but basically like that's what we do is
we [__] stuff up because we can't sit
still
what's like the famous quote of like all
of humans problems exist because we
can't just sit silently by ourselves a
man can't sit alone in a room for 30
minutes
yeah and um that's kind of the issue
here and it's kind of sucks because i'm
in the same boat
i know that if i just played it like i
i'm even
more conservative than fang i'm like s p
500 i'm like
so long as the hundred trailing hundred
years repeats itself like if i don't
think the trailing 100 years is gonna
repeat itself and there's probably like
huge problems with america
right and so i'm like as long as that
trailing hundred repeats itself like
right like everything's gonna be great
and days like day today happen and i'm
like oh [__]
gotta do this gotta do that gotta do
this right
um yeah so so i guess like that i was
a little bit long-winded in that i don't
think i really nailed my point
my point is when there's a real mega
trend
what feels like ah it's already played
out nope
there's a lot more to go and the hard
part of course is figuring out what's
the real what's a real mega trend what's
not
but in retrospect they were sort of
obvious mobile was a mega trend
video is a mega trend internet was a
mega trend and i believe crypto is a
mega trend
um and so you know those are those are
mega trends and
you know i remember i texted my dad
today
i go hey today's a great day to buy
bitcoin bitcoin's 30
off it's black friday and uh and
because every day he badgers me like
he's like oh you've been talking about
bitcoin since it was at 500 and then it
got to 2000 i thought it was too much
then it got to four thousand it got to
twenty thousand i thought no way this
goes above twenty thousand
and then you know recently it's been
sitting at fifty sixty thousand and he's
like now i
can't if i buy in i'm buying it fifty
sixty thousand i should have bought it
so did he do it
so i told him i said hey you've been
bitching and moaning about this like
here it is it's at 30 something thousand
go buy now is the time to buy and i know
what's gonna happen he's gonna think
well now it's in the red now it's not
hot you know
now i'm a little bit afraid because the
whole market's afraid and uh
so now he'll either not do it or he'll
like tiptoe in and then he'll regret it
later like i only put in so much
because that's just like classic
psychology of an investor right
of a bad investor i should say and um
and so so i guess like the the thought
process for me here is that
if you think this is a mega trend even
50k
is it's not too late because it still
has so much more room to grow if this is
true
now of course it could be wrong could
not be it could fall over it could fail
for many reasons
but i think that when you identify these
things the one of the worst mistakes you
can make
is either selling too early because you
don't write out the
you don't ride out the winner and then
the second i think mistake i think you
can make is
feeling like you're late when history
tells us that these things play out over
like a 20 30-year arc
i agree with everything i'm i'm nervous
that
because i don't i'm not the most
education i have on bitcoin is you
telling me
whatever you like whatever what you tell
everyone else is
like this is this is my education on it
um because it just doesn't interest me
other than sticking it to the man
um right and i have doubts
but not i mean i'm six figures in so
not that many doubts but uh maybe i'll
take your advice
and do it well i would say like you know
you never uh you know
probably the the best advice i could
give is never invest on somebody else's
conviction
because um when they're wrong it it it
it really
leaves a bad taste in your mouth because
you didn't believe to begin with well i
believe in the premise of like
you know like the government doesn't
control it no one controls it like it's
kind of crazy that
you know yeah i agree in the high-level
premise i think
what i'm saying is i think you want to
take somebody's if you hear my
conviction the answer is not go do it
the answer is
go learn for yourself and ask yourself
how much conviction do i have in this
and then invest proportionate to your
conviction because then at the very
least
when you're right or wrong you're gonna
you're gonna assign the credit or blame
to yourself
and you'll have a either a lesson
learned if you were wrong or a lesson
learned if you were right
about how much you followed your
conviction and if your conviction was
based in something real
and so uh anyways not financial advice
that's not my point my point was sort of
like
i thought it was very interesting
observation that
sometimes it's the the simplest
investment strategies
where you where you set it and you hold
it you leave it actually will outperform
and one of the reasons people don't do
them
is it's almost so stupid it's
embarrassing if that's your strategy
especially if your job is to be
an investment you know manager a
financial manager or financial advisor
then it's really embarrassing to just
recommend such a brain dead approach
uh but history will tell us that that
often that is the best returns
great well i think that's a great place
to end i always like ending in those
rants
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like my days off on a
roll let's travel never looking back